because good evening everybody we'll
just start by reading out the emergency
evacuation announcement should we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the building by the
nearest available exit there was one
fire exit in this room if you need to
evacuate the room do so by the glass
door to the external fire escape
staircase
please hold both handrails and press the
stairs in wet or slippery if anyone is
our unaided user stairs but they please
and our others to exit the room before
they go to the fire escape door but they
can be given assistance our central
point would be in the public car park at
the side of the Civic suite please do
not delay your back to collect
employment please do not return this
building until given permission to do so
by counsel staff please note that the
meeting will we all do recorded and can
I please reminder to switch your front
of society's gender by symbol on
apologies or absent substitute member
counselor mrs. lovely
just remember just go over it and
summarize it for us si mm - the nicety
major instant all which the bunch of
this summarizes quite in-depth timeline
it's attached as Appendix 1
the incident took place in August and
remembers to notice the actions which
will be taken for any equipment failure
which are moving the major incident
report that's attached yeah also you may
have had separate to you the minutes of
the ICT project migration review group
meeting that works on Friday and some of
the questions from that were in
connection with the report as well I've
summarized in here just the events of
what happens because it was a quiet and
they can do major event that took place
we had two events one was an equipment
failure watch reading the other was a
failure at we support start/stop pull
throughout the incident managing
director there metagame is on page seven
with the major incident repairs I was
the officer that was the instant
yes Thank You chairman if you could even
do one of one of the things on part of
the things having read this youth major
incident report was that where does our
DC fits in with their end user do we get
treated as priority or well these all
have a list of prioritized people or all
in yourself does the captain of
questions later and the other thing a
couple of other things is the what's
there or do you know of any backup power
supply to a new service and whether we
actually have a parallel system going to
those where we could the obviously if
there was backup and that parallel
system would kick in and serve us we we
understood that their meeting where you
said the systems were monitored or I
believe you said all the daily basis so
where was we with that the
I take them in yeah oh yeah you're
saying about the edgy so prioritizing us
as anybody else I mean for this
particular incident it was a complete
outage and electrical issue so everybody
was out and they worked through to get
as many of the basically to get the
equipment working first the electrical
problem working first and then they
brought up the data same time as we
would in that situation so I don't know
when I started to get there but they
started bringing back all of the service
and as soon as they got the electricity
back from the service warranty I'm
working as part of the the major instant
report from every serve they did that in
a as controlled manner as possible but
we also had to have control that coming
back of those service as well I don't
know what the was there a backup power
supply yes there was and that was
affected by the electrical issue that
they had as well again I don't have full
details of what that was but we have
their major incident report embers how
they count with that parallel systems
I'm getting your meaning the backups
that we had
they didn't evolve a disaster recovery
which would have been off-site because
they would have taken away the backups
would have been put onto the server's
other site what that would have meant
was we would have had to take miss down
they would have got us back up from
working in which they understood they
could do in fairly quickly
it was just equipment they needed they
could get the electricity back had they
have taken us onto another site and
tried to get us back up and working we
then would have had downtime a second
time we must have went straight back
into the data the original data center
so they took the right decision in
monitor today the on a daily basis our
systems are monitored on a daily basis
but this was an event that that was
unknown to them and they was nothing
they could do it happened outside of
their data center it was a contractor
that was on the site around the estate
that they are on that caused the problem
and so you know they were alerted as
soon as possible move the same as
anybody else in their datacenter
everything just went down and there was
no interest at all just one point is
that if the HC did that we're talking
about was caused by a displacement of
electrical services can you ask any
serve for their backup procedures and
have they got any backup procedures
because all data should have a UPS or
some sort of niche ad generator or
whatever backup system and that if they
haven't got that we should ask them yeah
for clarification why and you know what
what is there what's their thoughts on
that
the doorman from you said earlier their
their contingency is another off-site
Pentastar super Ranger at that dates
have been in any way compromised at all
then it is off-site yes because of the
nature of what it was was electrical but
there was you know
datings not be compromised in any way at
all it was just probably similar to ours
although it was an equipment failure
which they they did and they evoked
business continuity in that way and then
gone down for the us to be then
transferred back into the original data
center a few questions dawn
if you don't mind one is the point of
mine the detail on paragraph two point
five it mentions the 22nd of September
of the German state control yes thank
you thank you
the edge of serves technician he seemed
to take a long while to reach Rutherford
was he placed in Swindon
yes it so has traveled all the way from
Swindon to Oxford he did right thank you
it seems that they're quite vulnerable
with having our telephone service
interconnected with our data streams
would be far safer to have those there's
a separate issue yeah
because we couldn't get out to the
outside in any way and one last point
something I'm a bit unclear on section
2.1 it mentions a feed having flatlined
some 2150 on Friday of the problems it
mentions a field that flatlined 2150 on
Friday evening yeah
was that the commencement of the problem
yes so that was Friday evening that's
and we weren't aware until Monday
morning that's right because because
that's happened to our end and so we
don't have anybody on site well so we
wasn't aware of that happens we don't
ever give anybody on site out okay so
that's all thank you very much oh thank
you so just a quick question it's
probably not something that would expect
you to answer necessarily but has anyone
to your knowledge ascertained how many
hours of work were lost through this
outage and the impact on the staff from
the council services I don't know if
American jury
[Applause]
do you know if there's any makes me
attempt to climb back running costs
because obviously Eddie server saying
it's a third party that created the
problems are there but we have a
contract with them they have a contract
and presumably if someone creates an
issue where there is consequential loss
that loss should become be able to be
compensated for have the cassock
investigate thank you very much thank
you thank you John thank you for that
something else is out there there's also
there's no ask them
I think about the parallel working
nothing caused us I'm disappointed too
that he's in such that he could be
switched quickly right only if they're
dead for the moment I think stop we're
just learning query about our our
disaster recovery or bursts or parts of
it he seems to me that I didn't request
this console comes on to this review
committee and I had to request it by
original handwritten letter to the
managing director the chairman of the
committee and mr. Gower was hopefully
you got your handwritten letter both of
you I had no phone numbers to call there
were no fun no no phone numbers we call
there were no emails the only way I
would speak to an officer would be to go
to the office fairly member that's a
problem but for a group leader that's
incredibly embarrassing at times so
I think they should we would appear to
have been missing a very basic level of
putting something into action to prevent
their happening that we reduced the
handwritten letters that that doesn't
seem right what have we looked at that
now onto the website met as a leadership
team to take their numbers together and
get them swiftly up into the website we
had web chats we had offices that were
at what point did they go into it what
what day what time did they don't the
phone numbers going to the I can't
realize our own situation was one that
was very major to us because at the time
we didn't know what the outage was we
didn't know what the problem was and so
we've got together to decide how much of
the business continuity planning to put
in place and in offices in their own
areas service areas business continuity
plan
and was it possible for temporary emails
to be assigned to officers members no
maybe since I'm sorry I said something
but we had we had laptops out to people
obviously were prioritizing that because
we had to prioritize so mobile website
was actually working so as much
information we knew more that was
happening as it was evolving because at
the start of it at the incident
obviously we need very little and as we
were going through the next couple of
days then leaving you more and more so
we would put ignore that business
continuity assistant directors are
putting business continuity plans but
needs to employees because they're
different depending on if it's one day
in two days you know different things so
that we don't see if I can be done
quicker next time and remembers
absolutely I mean if it's one thing you
know we do things in a you know
emergency situation we have emergency
planning and we have incidents where we
serve people pretends that this outage
has happened we've actually been able to
do it for real so that one way is that
the things that we've learned you know
we're still picking up now
to put some of those things in place
with regard to the catastrophic failure
and reserve we were aware of that act
1310 on day three when were they aware
of it without we're all day one what
imagine if there was catastrophic
failure but they're in they would know
about it fairly quickly it wouldn't take
them three days to find out did they
know and they came to us they left to
come back the next day and they as I
understand it realized they had a
problem on the Tuesday morning when we
couldn't get in contact with them if you
look at the details in the actual
appendix we couldn't get hold of so so
if I'm reading this wrong well they
won't was that more than one incident
then yes I understand did one calls the
other is no no I did not
we were never to complete one completely
separate issues the first issue was our
switch them out and we had a place to
deal with that just completely you know
we've not been able to predict it at all
and you serve then had this catastrophic
issue at their data center which was on
day two yes and then then they're told
to lunch time on day three that that was
the case yes right and
thank you putting it carefully to avoid
mate just know about not knowing numbers
several weeks ago I think it was he
remembers draws a whole list of all the
direct lines and mobile numbers for all
the officers are printed it off at home
Doric lines can work would like a little
bit more numbers are on there is that
might would have been after the event
Lee know the ways before the event
rocket yeah printed elf several weeks
ago was an email then I think it might
have been in the members drug yeah
that's by email to clarify that it was
on the way the state after all phone
Dean after the uses on the mountings she
won Scranton actually sent an email to
all members of six mobile phone numbers
know that it's not that this is about
four pages long and now this was six six
mobile numbers that can be contacted
before it was yeah okay all leaders
should have numbers in any case Tom Tom
Thank You chairman firstly apologize for
chairman the committee I had my own Ltd
my current service boy I'm a bit like
this evening but my question is relates
to after the event as as they've been
any other
IT issues of cause the failure or
disruption to services to the general
public since
it's a that failures or just any any
issues no harm away of one that the
payment system for council tax was not
valuable for a period of time so i was
just wondering if there's been any other
incidents IT issues which are disrupting
a service system the general public
yes we have heard over the last week and
a half we've had some issues with our
service that's not anything but because
they're not being managed properly it's
just simply we now need to just move
into the cloud we're going to you know
we're going to get these things happen
occasionally now until we move because
as we know we're on unsupported servers
and we are doing the best with the
resources that we have in maintaining
them the service to the public being the
website port always aware and when
they're coming through to us the systems
have been slow so it's taken a little
bit longer to be able to process
somebody on the phone and there's been
some latency with some of the
applications as well in processing them
how did you serve in to help us with
that and these the systems at the moment
have been quite stable I think it's
probably
couple of other members of any painting
to asking questions I've got a couple
myself actually and it seems to me quite
keen quite important that we were
involved in this it says that the end of
it draw it a recommendation historical
more formal agreement with South in ICT
tip as every serves table too far away
to react with quickly to instantly how's
that going and what's the progress on
that yeah I've got a meeting with the
director that Stefan's on Tuesday the
network people have done a matter of
working with some documentation to get
the forest because obviously there they
were on the site
and the conversations I've got a brief
conversation with their director and
make white bean also to work with us
because of their business continuity so
I think I'll put on those something back
to Fox and the batter basically has
everything in it we keep this
there's a male site so we're going to
jointly work together in understanding
what we can do to give us more
resilience so to me if they made their
network team shoes day next week to
finalize and put down some sort of
service level agreements they surveys
the essex online partnership that I put
in there did come into its own and we
were able to really quickly identify
wasn't just Southend with others as well
as quickly identify where we could get
equipment where we could get network
expertise that they don't have ourselves
so as you say yeah absolutely
didn't coming into its own it makes
sense to us to do this out then they
have their own data center themselves so
we've had to swifting quickly move
anything from our server room we could
do that much quicker than we can to that
particular seems to me to imply that we
are more reliant on the receipt from own
only in as much as I mean our service of
live to be registered this is this is
what we have on site they're not
responsible for that
anyway so calling a geo serve was
outside of the of the arrangements with
them but again we it was outside the the
normal managed service that they managed
was because it's on our site and we're
responsible for it but we had the SLA
with them to say should we need to call
on them then they would come in and
offer us the assistance because they had
the net
and then work expertise in which to do
that but again you know we we've gone
through this emergency situation realize
that actually isn't the best thing to do
it's not registered to have that with
revenge yourself because they're just
simply too far away so we need to have
some arrangement some of the other
between each other we now we we didn't
have direct contact with clarinet
they're very close software company and
if the basic for your name's not on the
list they won't speak to you
and so that course it's a little bit of
a problem because we haven't really
realized that we thought we could ring
up and say what actually we're Rochford
and we've got the link with you so you
know can we discuss and can you can you
check had to do is get a juicer to do
that as a third party so we had to say
to which the penny wing them and ask
them to do this can you move them to
check that so which other set of dick do
for us because the actual contract is
with a juicer not with much room so
we're going to we're going to move that
and so that he's going to be with us and
we've already I think
one just last point B just to move to
reporting this incident just can you
just clarify that as far as I'm aware
and I think I've seen a response yes it
was as far as I'm known it was with the
IC on the 23rd they were contacted and
throughout the the incident we had I had
the assistant director legal services
manager at all and I think it's in I'm
sure it's in the young agent that was
one of the watch had incident support
officers Romney said that I was
informing and she was helping me there
was going to be anything that we needed
to pick up quickly around that but we
did report it there wasn't any issues
Thank You chairman just another couple
of things which you remarked on a little
bit was that business continuity test
has as they have we tested this just or
will we test it in the future I mean
should it happen again sort of thing
I'll be nobody can tell but I mean if we
go then we've got some sort of way round
to keep continuity of what we're doing
and the other thing was which when I
asked that the meeting was there any
cost of elaborated from this come come
forward this switch
what's which are we talking I mean this
I know it's only a small amount of 275
pound it's very small amount compared to
what we've already spent on the IT
system but what was the switch boy
exactly another replacement switch so
that Sydney know we're now server rooms
should we have an incident with that
switch case so though be close fence
which is yeah they replaced the switch
so we had already had a replacement
switch that was put in but now I haven't
got another one so about three another
one you've just enjoyed yeah yeah thank
you and that is the right I mean charges
have you paid you set the cost of the
switch is that is that for register what
is that for real
yeah is it I thought these beats boys
basic
yeah I mean our own switch issue very
swiftly because we stress which we could
put in we've learned that having energy
service our network expertise isn't
really the best thing to do so South in
so that again we'll have very quickly so
from that incident you know we put
things in place and continue to look at
it I'm not just going to stay with that
instant happen then so right done you
know we'll continue to monitor it and
continue to look at for improvements as
far as they do serve you know hopefully
that incident doesn't happen again and
being a bit
lessons learned and then put things into
place and contingency things into place
that I hope won't happen but again we
were in their hands as we wouldn't be
because we were in their data center at
that point and just have reassured you
that they are in their decline edge we
serve put on the internet in January
that they're coming out of the
directives data center business anyway
so that they're actually migrating their
customers to the azure cloud in fact it
looks like their business is going to
become support for clients who have
their applications in the cloud so the
situation with AG serve is that they
will be ceasing a data center business
and of course we will be out of their
data center and into the Microsoft Azure
servers much quicker than they will
cease their business
I believe we're talking about the end of
October to have completed both 365 and
the migration of all applications to the
cloud
except team one which is in the cloud
[Music]
my greatest
[Music]
[Music]
so this report just presents the draw
housing and home response gene which
sets the priorities and direction for
housing years it was born out really on
the fact that we needed to do a homeless
review which were new hire especially
because of the new legislation and the
new duties and I consider the fact that
whilst we publish this is a standalone
strategy it was an opportunity to start
linking the Y developments that impact
on homeless prevention and homeless work
into their strategies so we've started
to gather a bit of information data
intelligence etc around housing supply
of audibility private housing and the
inherent linking of housing and health
as well so the strategy was it poured
all the information together as set out
and for powers these four core
priorities have been identified areas
rob people plays property partnerships
all of which have been developed in
response to the information gathered and
have regard to the prep
national policies that will come about
recently most in the summer breaker to
say and local and corporate context and
of course the most important part of the
strategy is the action plan which is
where we're saying we're going to make
things happen over the next five years
and begin the purpose of this report is
to get this committee sink Norseman for
this draft so we can consult more widely
bearing in mind we have already
consulted together Thank You chairman
there are three things that I was
concerned that I didn't see explicit in
the action plan so with me if you placed
it somewhere I didn't make it one of the
things that I think we need to look at
in terms of actions is considering how
to increase the number of affordable
homes on developments over fifteen
thirty five percent doesn't seem enough
to meet our needs for our homeless
registry and I didn't see in action for
the council to consider an alternative
policy from the second place I wondered
if there could be a policy where there
are new developments that there is a
greater skew towards the lower priced
properties because we know that younger
people or people without particular
means are finding it very difficult to
find somewhere to buy if that is the way
they wish to approach it I think it's
always quite evident service all over
the developers give their development
towards the larger properties Allroad I
think is a classic example of how that
and the smaller properties are actually
much lower in terms of proportion so I
wonder how we could have an action to
create a policy
change the skew towards those people who
want or like or affordable pounds
properties and the third part is
something that is causing residents a
great deal of angst and a great deal of
rumor and that is how do we prevent
these smaller properties being sold to
other authorities to benefit their
housing register rather than house and
of course there are inherent risks that
will come with those people in that we
take responsibility for them in the
event they want to move so I've got
three things that I couldn't see
explicit in our action plan for policy
change and I can't I mean obviously some
of those are not necessary to answer
this is what it's all about consulting
on the draft and I agree with counsel
Mason they're not explicitly there in
the action plan and to tend to some of
those would be quite difficult as you
say we can do policies but we concern
the influence a lot especially around
the planning and the affordability side
and the the smaller properties etc
regarding the properties that may be
getting sold to other local authorities
and bring in outside people into our
district again I don't know I mean
certainly we can take steps which we're
already doing at county level which are
trying to do that I think we couldn't do
it on our own we have to do it with
counting and when we're doing it with
the east of England and local authority
you never recognize that there's a piece
of so there's a piece of work taking
place within safer Essex at the moment
it's very issue because it's recognized
that actually a number of London
boroughs are trying to send the
residents to s6 particular to Harlow so
it's recognised actually that is quite a
significant initiative we are not
potentially we're not facing any watch
it at the moment very exerting something
that has been made you know Korean
hasn't been explicitly mentioned and
it's something because we're already
doing and obviously I want to continue
to do chairman could I just respond I'm
glad you recognized those three years I
think
they're not explicit in the action plan
I know if we don't include them we're
going to get in the consultation
requests arguments criticisms that we
haven't so I'd encourage the council to
consider enhancing the action plan in
those particular areas thank you just
carrying on from there actually and this
is a historically and now homeless have
been housed outside of the district so
could you give me the figures at the
moment are we still housing a lot of our
homeless as there is the shortages
pointed out outside the district or here
in my firm only we're not housing
Moroney housing people that's like the
district my emergency accommodation as
we know and our numbers in B&B as you
know through previous reports have gone
down dramatically because of Angelou's
of Tempe combination but the current
numbers in bed and breakfast which are
outside of magistrate online good and I
asked that because it goes a lot of
relevance to the person in the family
being housed outside of here in the
district and my question is in relation
to the plan on page seven point four
four zero the middle paragraph
underpinning thought about working with
social housing providers to ensure they
identified at an early stage tenants in
rates Venturi's or otherwise a twisted
prediction excellent obviously they're
quite easy to identify
and then when we go to page seven point
four so we're looking to do the same
private landlords how easy is that going
to be sorry some of my fortune some come
for three actually on it says for
private tenants homeless clients to
quickly and effectively we sold half
helping issues with better understanding
of housing standards and
responsibilities and this is in yes I
think that's more not about I mean
obviously if they're going to be evicted
you would encourage them to get housing
advice but that was more about giving
tenants a bit like a ton of
accreditation service different tenants
some skills and responsibility is to
find private rented accommodation become
their own surveillance and things like
that so this is where our private
housing officer is going to be working
or is already working with our housing
luxury service to put together a
responsibilities are the standard it
wasn't necessarily around what to do if
you get an eviction notice it was more
about support move to get to Tennessee
and once you see what because if you're
working with social housing land not
snot and learning to identify tenants of
got into arrears so that you can support
them yeah it's the same process going to
happen with private landlords could we
look at that possibility we could
[Music]
certainly with those manuals that we've
got that relationship with us that's no
problem and
we rarely talk with them anyway so I'm
very happy to include that you know show
is 100.8 7.39 you're referred to we talk
about them delivery of appropriate
housing growth in water district I'm
using all the bad boy services to
deliver housing needs
I mean I need Thank You chairman I think
one of the questions have been asked and
you've answered that with the known
government's view at least that the
council should be now because of not
getting the 35% affordable housing is
that the council should start a program
of building their own and I think that's
that comes with the base report that you
should be able to network with I don't
know if that's available you know one
thing my other question is how many
tenants if you like or whoever they are
how you want to put it is now in private
accommodation
and is that private accommodation up to
the standards of what I mean do we
inspect the accommodation and is that
inspection carry there and and gives you
up to scratch are they up to scratch
with it are you happy with that
situation I can't be honest I can't tell
you exactly how many people have been
placed over the last quarter cup of
quarters into private rented and I do
know it's being extremely successful
because obviously I've got more
resources in the team and they've got
better relationships with letting agents
I need to reassure you that the where
they're people we don't directly place
clients we just introduce clients to the
landlord then I'm going to SPECT the
property etc and that's the whole point
of us trying to give them more skills to
know how to respect that property but
saying that our homeless prevention
officers are actually going to have a
look at these properties before they're
going to you know it's something if a
netting agent said we've got one or two
events available normally what happens
part of that relationship ability they'd
go and have a look at them and also if
there's any concerns genuine you want
people who are in tennessee's and what
they're doing now is they're calling on
the private housing officer to have a
dog because they've got to know we don't
to you sorry just come back obviously
the the the people that are renting I'm
not skilled in their sort of thing is to
know what is what they're acceptable and
what isn't acceptable so yeah thank you
very much for that because we don't let
me tell you see - no no obviously we
don't know thank you thank you Jeff
I just like to reaffirms they put the
castle mice was making about the 35% and
the concern that it's 35 percent of
properties the smallest one not 35
percent of bedrooms and I do think
that's something we should look at the
other thing that concerns me and I don't
know if we can do anything about is that
when they're 15 and under we don't have
any affordable housing
perhaps that element could be looked at
as well
has just changed so has the new national
planning policy framework excuse me I'm
not completely proficient in that but it
hasn't really changed so developments
between and 10 and 15 now have 10% they
actually can 10% of those need to be
affordable now that only being a small
number but it's better than what it yes
but I'll read a document also yes
absolutely you already have and we've
had a capital as a result of that but
the the percentage shouldn't be the
number of properties it should be the
capacity and that would make quite a
difference if they're giving 2-bedroom
properties 15% 35% and there are YouTube
important the others are 3/4 thinking or
is just emotional and I think that's
something that we should look at under
our policy and the second I'm not sure
this is the correct place for it but at
risk that has asked me to bring this up
it's a situation where someone was
evicted for a private rented
accommodation because of rent arrears
and damaged allow can't won't give any
details obviously but they've been
advised that they will be re-homed ivory
District Council
it's that normal situation I mean
normally we would help people but
sometimes it would appear that I mean if
we just that information and look or you
could even I hope it's anything I would
about studying my case identity just if
you just said that when it's and I
probably said categorically no but
there's probably a slightly bigger
yes so he athletes um talk about outside
me thank you
yeah so then I was just requested to
bring it out cuz I think they were
concerned about me thank you you know I
just wanted to go back home for
Christmas pain about private rented
accommodation and you thought like
trying to like introduce them so they
let him agency and all that I just
wanted to convert because if I went to
different election agency first thing I
would have to do is do a credit check
and they could charge me anything from
250-pound the contractor parent so do
these people have to pay that because I
know for further cost read about 20 quit
another credit check on anyone we've
seen takes quite a while to build up
relationships with the lectin agency in
particular agencies and thank you um I
get the impression that when you talk of
affordable homes you're talking in one
and two-bedroom properties as you're
aware I have been in touch with you know
about a family that needs a four-bedroom
property and I'm being told that you're
desperately short of what is being done
about that size of property I personally
can't post that in detail because I
probably had to talk to plans but at the
moment
it's probably I know there are families
out there with better knowledge but at
the moment we're not sure so he'll be
done about that in these cards directly
probably influenced that I can certainly
talk to plan is about it seems to be a
magic problem doesn't it well there's a
need for all kinds of it's certainly
there is it great to me for one two
minutes but you know there's a need for
all kinds of and I would say there isn't
there is and that will be on that will
be online so obviously it will be there
for the wider residents obviously we're
and social media that but also it's
going to go with and without our
partners that attended a homeless for
them
this year so it's likely stakeholders
ranging from health County and others
community safety partners health and
well-being partners
that's the forum is successful it was
successful it's 40 plus and participants
roundtable some members here attended
service a roundtable just getting to
understand while the review online our
aspirations and getting thought some
ideas around a homeless Charter which is
really our intention to obviously our
aspiration to end homelessness and a set
of values around how we can work
together and respect those that come
through our doors there's a good range
of stakeholders are attended myself and
it's good to see number of community
groups a number of local churches with a
forward we're going to everyone together
we know different positions when we were
nice thank you come back around the
bedroom sizes of four thousand was
raised was it make me slightly concern
because obviously for any major
application discussions are helping
their housing officer and they will say
yes or no to that mix of housing it's
just slightly worried there's two bits
these are slightly worried about you see
we think that I'm not a with it with are
you are we saying that that is not that
influential and we were finished
effectively agreeing what we've told
he's going to happen or is he just
question that the mix is quite going to
get and we do you know we do get the
conversations do we
what a housing readings but so that
leads onto the second thought which has
just cursed me sighs weakly I apologized
to Peter nor rather than thought on the
basis that each application comes in and
we are and I assume then what we are are
saying this is the type of housing we
need at the moment is walnut he's on our
list how often it's that review because
I can see a situation where you've just
said if there is a delay building houses
that we're forever short to one and two
bedroom houses and that's always going
on because of the delay in building so
it is reviewed really yes so for
instance Marcus the concern is that if
we passed many a people if we're passing
as a number of applications so for
instance if I have to take haul road
that I don't know what the mixture was
on there that was passed but we think
it's being built I hope we've just been
passed that would be built in next few
months and output car for five years
building that mixed house which I think
was was made two or maybe three bedrooms
from memory but maybe since one-bedroom
flats as well however before that was
passed the ones already were passed and
they would be passed with the mixture at
that time so I'm just wondering how that
maybe should a jerk of what's been
passed at the moment would affect our
housing list so if all those if
everything was built at the moment which
is being passed with the housing mixture
we've asked for would that can I can we
just let me coming back to me and the
line without the members ought to know
how that would affect our housing mix ie
how many 1 bedroom 2 or 3 bedroom 4
bedroom and how that equates to our
Housing Register at the moment
significant delay whether it's still
because some of you built before others
and I'm wondering how that will pay
around I'm probably not quite a 5-mile
to that exactly no sure and I can get
back to you and give you more D to say
you know just met many that obviously
our housing needs has to changed a great
deal
certainly in my time just at a common
they're going from memory I believe in
the Hall Road the developers did come
back to us and ask to restructure given
the number of properties and the sizes
and so sometimes market forces will have
an effect without the influence of
leaders I think there's a change of
spine by the links between buying and
Betty but this idea was so changed
history from 1820 to 1730
getting to be precise is actually a
question about the report is a question
for us to you mr. chairman I just
noticed that we're being asked to
endorse it a pork normally would note of
course there's only reason for that
change of version
I pretty much happier to know too
it's bearing in mind that it's going to
consultation I think we should be
knowledge again noticing it one Thank
You chairman with my ears and taken
getting on the property led room
whatever event and busies from the news
star but we've recently had in the way
of youngsters or you know trying to get
on the property ladder is the canceled
viewing a strategy that's some other
councils are taking boy helping those to
get on the property ladder in Wales
partnership or some sort of description
like that do you happen to others are
doing here or going to do it at the
moment and I just wondering if that one
if that might come to to yourself so the
split 7030 80/20 they are others are
shared ownership but I don't think
they're restricted to our areas I think
that's the problem that is done
I'm a terrible that their contractors
don't operate their own schemes because
we were offered that on the whole bridge
I'm development than that was rejected
by the housing officer because I said it
wasn't good
mr. chairman says report so it is happy
clear and they have been she said to
read the report it in summary it so it
summarizes other things how we have a
monitor the contracts with fusion some
of the investments in the site the date
some of the broader sports development
work that we undertake with the with the
contracted a we have a partnership
relationship infusion lifestyle to
manage the facilities both parties are
striving for the best outcomes high
quality community facilitate indeed as
part of their trance projectors as a
shooting our charity to deliver those
high quality facilities we do carefully
and consistently monitor the contract we
have a clear contract with them and
we've reported before in terms of how we
do that and that's true
ultimately the issuing of more notices
when service falls below the acceptable
standards it's probably worth noting to
the I suppose main areas of focus
officers recently trusted contract has
been cleanness and pace across the
across the facility and just a bit of
detail to that times of cleanliness
we've raised issues with them previously
in terms of sending us across the across
the portfolio marks issued notices on
occasion where that has fallen below a
certain set the standard the attractive
held meetings with their own contractor
claims we have seen some improvements in
the area but the obvious there's much
work to be done there but I think the
general direction travel with is is
positive in terms of place we want to
see improvements made much more quickly
that's for the small scale an amount a
bigger scale in terms of updates on that
side fusion themselves and may the a
change for edges recently in their
management structure which has meant
that the contract manager so the office
of this or the member of staff
responsible for overseeing the whole
contract across fusion
it's been some additional resources and
now to free up their time able them to
focus more on some of the bigger issues
across the sites and to increase that
pace of delivery so that's watching
break for us to see if that does have
the desired effect we're hopeful again
the duration of travel is positive the
reports clarifies and highlight some
investment across two sites recently
which I'm sure members will be pleased
to see we say welcome as officers under
7,000 pounds in the gym in terms of new
spin bikes CB equipments and other fits
in there in terms of real decorative
mats and also 60,000 pounds to come in
the website acclaim as well as a sensor
we appreciate much more work to be done
fusions that you do as well if they were
here tonight they're probably saying
similar things
we do recognize cessation travel as
improved we feel but much more work to
be done and certainly mention for weeks
and months will continue that pressure
and part of unions or those improvements
more than happy to take any questions
members may have
I welcome the the news that the
investment has gone into our local
region facilities that's wonderful news
on a slightly different note the the
hard targeting area that's what I would
like to know about what has been put in
place to address that I know the police
was involved counselor where's Marty
okay well totally have really taken him
advice from the please German so come to
give them first you have to talk Harding
so four members aren't aware this refers
to the recent most from the most reason
travel incursion at his sites few months
back we met with senior police officers
to a great plan that having kids do our
best to avoid happen in the future
ver vitae was to look at quitting some
more purpose gates to the from the
carpark to the open space area and to
the front of the facility of the main
entrance
so halfway through that work and the
gate has been fitted to thee from the
car parts you have anticipate and this
is a these are more robust gates with
you know Monty cropped bars more robust
pillars etc so that they should be able
to get through all to the open space
should be another incursion and the next
states that work it to fit a similar
gate to the front of the intensity as
well so let's take through police advise
that's the first start to that process
to hope you stop happening again
although no Sykes is fully secured but
we can do our best to tidy colonies is
the phrase that the police use and will
certainly follow though right
let's follow through thank you
yes thank Jimmy I believe this is people
before review before there was some
comments that were made about some early
early work looking at the contract and
renewal coming up have hypothesis began
or started to do some some early
preparation work for the contract result
[Music]
yep certainly the focus referred members
to the report section 3.19
just give some help system headings over
the place what we have been doing today
a minister's words be going out for some
months now it might be leading on
certainly it's looking at and it's
something we've been doing for for some
months now every time I see a writer for
the contract be a how it's monitors
responsibilities and Freedmen's we can
make note of that it's an old contract
it's over 20 years ago
we're coming towards the end yes it's
there's a lot of improving things with
with continually doing that we've
already met with sports England again
some months back to seek their advice in
terms of the best way to do this process
in terms of consultation and what they
can look like Mars between with other
colleagues their primitive similar bits
of work to see what we can learn from
them or what didn't work so well and
also again looking at other potential
contracts and options of how we run the
service so an ongoing brief that's we're
ahead of the game but we're not at that
time we'll run them very quickly so they
happy to move quickly to move to a
position where we can make some
decisions I'll just raise a question
around the running of the contractors at
the moment then just move on to the
future delivery options
oh we're going to do my feet up so I
should be slightly commercially
sensitive if you give too much weight in
I would declare an interest in that I do
you Israeli then you said quite a lot
looking at me you might wonder what is
actually to drink coffee I drink I do
they're not big clients there and it is
incredibly annoying the amount of times
the cafe there is closed off spec into
the staff there and talking with care so
this is what has been me it's really the
last time and they technically please
call complain to me because is he's just
not the the contractor does not care
about it to me it's part of the of what
should be their tenants all has a cafe
they used to be a cafe there which was
open and this might as well it's not as
though it's closed at 10 o'clock or not
I'm talking about a Saturday morning at
nine o'clock when it really should be
opening these clothes because they're
refusing to start it can you just have a
look at that
so I think that's a really important
part of the lecture center I think it's
very more than the saying take that away
over there yeah I know that it is I know
it start of the sense of a ghost
reception they can make meaning some
coffee yes principal place will take
that always you look at why that isn't a
reasons for and get muscle and then I
move on to the second part not Frankie
whose general and we're talking about
the renewing the delivery option in line
with our business plan presumably as I
see that that would be to keep people
active or to maximize our assets and the
two might not be or may be mutually
exclusive I'm not sure that's probably
something you'll be looking at I should
have asked this before but can someone
come back with me for a figure for me
can you let me know how many what the
percentage of the adult population is of
Rochford which he's a member of head of
the Jim
so now who've lost a lot of how many
people put on support for a more
percentage days off of the total
population please
same way because that sound only kind of
names I should because that is the
important figure to know because it was
a bolt on to yours because some of them
might not be members that may use yes
there's a specific reason market for
members okay
there is a reason for it and I just
wanted to know the figure I understand
what you say but he was the membership I
wanted if I saw something come back my
figure NGA tapuwae okay the focus point
is that yes indeed because the make sure
the site summer members but all year
long as we know you're paying play you
see so they might turn up on the day so
you won't have that information so the
figures Rick isn't both thing like the
you saw in effect but it'll be it might
be supposed to be pointing weekend
that's fine a bit I'm thinking and from
there just let me well very briefly to
ask how you're gonna do with this I'll
be quite critical of how the they're
currently contractors or I'll show you
aware of that
it used they used to be a lot
more activities to try and encourage
people who don't normally or normally
active to become active the serene class
is a lesson half of what they used to be
the when homes place ready so I'm going
back a long time it may be you're saying
that's the place before all of them but
I think that when we're looking at
renewing this we should even think we're
maximizing our asset which means we
maximize our asset or we're actually
really trying to get people active and
if you can do bad with it's brilliant
but I think at the moment we're failing
under getting people active without
incentives every top of a contractual so
I think the contracts incentive richer
than there is isn't there if I just come
into so many let's walk onto that I did
allude to some of the smaller element
work and it's in the report will let
mark pick up on some of the work because
there's an awful lot that's going on in
the background that mark works with with
the crap all that mark give you the year
so so if you define active part in the
active cultures the community activity
note we've got one of the new
initiatives this year is a weight
management program but they've
introduced working with ace AC lifestyle
so individuals are referred on to that
program get specialist advice from where
center staff through aces lifestyle the
organization the center center style
also given specific training solutions
to fall that start there's a 12-week
program drawing session they get
concessionary rates
centers so then still relatively new the
program but it's means a positive
feedback so far there's something
they're looking to expand further
they've also in the past being part of
the disco can national campaign which is
national campaign to draw a female
participation in sport and that's
something again have been discussions
with axe basics about their involvement
over the coming years is that we're the
festival running in the spring as part
of that Lincoln football is
runs at both the centres and the proved
very popular and continues to do so I
think generally trying to promote the
liberal ground so the County liberal
brand promoting small physical activity
and health and well-being across the
county is something that actually watch
diffusion and ourselves have accounts a
while we're looking to promote and there
will be an open day in the new year to
kind of open up the facilities to to the
whole community and another proof a
pocket in the past when they've run that
so I think most certainly over the kind
of the last or June 2018 there's been a
kind of a lot of positive work that
Fusion have done to target you know some
of those some of the groups they're not
otherwise participating in this way to
deter so I'm not convinced they're
reaching people thought the reason you
manage all get to do that as well so
when I was visiting example myself last
week I meant that he manager
Parvez rate he's actually supposed to
get the good news stories as well in
terms of everybody using the facilities
works and she did to them and improving
the lifestyles that was social media as
well because I'm it's a recognition or
not are you pushing yourself suppose
I've clicked on social media and that
was certainly partly managers involved
to do that incremental but so you're
saying this is going to reach people
outside of those who would normally go
to a gym facility might only the weight
management program certainly yeah it's
like to people that wouldn't only go to
the to the gym they're also looking at a
project work with young people with
mental health issues as for fiscal
activity has been shown through research
they were positive positive impacts
again that's another group will
necessarily look to a leisure center
somewhere they would you know
necessarily go to is it just average
I've been walking for one you touched on
is that aimed at the
Thank You chairman and actually marks
probably just almost my question because
my question is going to be as patient's
CIL what ditional services are they but
to no avail community now you've just
reeled off a whole lot of information
and none of that's in here and I think
that's really important that you should
be in here
the add-on that we're getting from them
as a charitable organisation that they
giving a to empowering community my only
other thoughts were if there are certain
times of the day where there's no
activity they're all low activity take
up who are they engaging with outside
was funding they active roster of access
and they put on some sessions older
people sessions there was a lot a
session that's continued beyond the
funding to run at freight house and that
stuff was actually example of using you
know space that was available wasn't it
they utilize during that during that
time of the day activity and the
customers that you have got to hurry to
run their own sessions and they've been
opportunity they're almost to reward
them to say well between 8 a.m. and 9
a.m. we have very neat work table do you
like this room to do one of your classes
in or something like that rather see it
being utilized you asking for an
inclusion in the report just to
highlight some of the initiatives I
think it's a nod to the contract
thank you yeah Thank You Sharon Matt how
would I refer to a direction of travel
going on cleanliness
I'd like to endorse back and one of the
members was talking in our pre meeting
though a huge number of complaints that
turned up in around July time from
residents who were complaining about the
cleanliness particularly the website and
other parts of the Clements hall one of
the residents became a spokesman for
that group of people and it was a lot
fairly large number and I've spent time
I think for months visiting Clemens Hall
with John Richardson and latterly with
Mark fusion have responded positively
they are moving in the right direction
there is more to do the residents are
reasonably assured that that is the way
things are going they are particularly
assured around what is going to happen
in the wet side of changing village and
there are there were quite a few ideas
that came forward from the residents
group the only thing that concerns me
and Mark knows this and he knows I'm
going to say fusion don't seem to
operate project management and they tend
to run these improvements you know on a
fairly ad hoc basis without
understanding dependencies and I think
they need to be in current you were
saying that they don't do things as
quickly yes and to be quite honest the
reason they don't manage that is because
they don't use project management skills
as part of the way forward and I've
encouraged John Richardson an amazing
fact the contract manager but I've
encouraged mark to work with him to
ensure that there is a project in place
and I will be dropping in in a month's
time to ask how that's how that's going
so it's an endorsement of good
but if that's gonna change wouldn't be
periodic it is a long con tribes are 20
contract men awarded so yeah we're
coming towards the end very very long
term contract because it benefits from
that and I think about some some
challenges too as well in terms of how
its reviewed its we have to see we'll
see that contract out in it it believe
increases with our pier Angeli so that's
it set from that figure it's how it
works so that will come to end there
will have a potted moving to commercial
sense of grounds but they'll be then
opportunity to review options but I
contract the most best outcomes for your
authority financially operationally and
also for the residents in terms of
quality providers and high quality of
services we want from those science I
believe it is BA great that know what is
ailing since a start
yes the works will take place during
December that was he looking to minimize
disruption to the science so that's
December is a Ottoman time to carry out
the works so yeah the jobs be on the
committee to complete the works fly
during the calendar year I've got Y
monthly meeting with the next week so
I've been agenda item there to discuss
thank you Thank You chairman mark you
mentioned some of these health programs
they're going to be very widely
publicized are they on the council
website is a matter of people picking up
leaflet I mean in terms of
communications we've had a couple of
months ago there was a meeting between
the communication teams from fusion and
from watchful District Council discuss
how where you could improve and work
more closely together to ensure that you
know when we have got some projects and
use new stores that actually the message
is getting out so press releases are
issues exiled posted on on social media
I think there is more work that can be
done to improve how we forget the
mystery and the short people are aware
of the opportunities that are there at
the center's Thank You mr. chair I think
we're all aware that a lot of our
residents at some stage of the other
going to hospital and young and old and
often the hospital these days will send
you away with a sheet and ask you to do
an exercise
they don't physiotherapy is not
something that's generally provided it's
scarce so that they give someone a
printout and they ask them to do these
exercises now to be encouraged to do
these exercises we brought this up
before when we had our visit if you a
call and then under use areas in both
Bailey and des chemins Halton and we
asked if it was possible for the
provider to supervise the exercise we're
not asking to do that tonight with South
in hospital or buzzient of that matter
to both use the underused areas so a
social aspect to the rehabilitation if
you know he could be broken from there
it could be a minor stroke I don't know
and to encourage improved physical
improvement which would be obviously
beneficial for the health of our
residents and both mental and physical
walls that ever investigated and what
was the result Jamie so in the past at
the site we have also funeral from GP
exercise and referral which takes a
similar scheme forgive me to mention
bore so that's something from previously
where children have had start trying to
able to deliver
an exercise program that GP woods with
designed to help of rehabilitation so
which member o'clock would go to the GP
maybe after an operation or for summary
presentation the cheaper would prescribe
exercise routine network with a person
trainer of the site's probably trained
to deliver that program at the sites I
don't know what position is about
current I know something popped in the
past region have right after check
little position is with it now but it's
a quality scheme it's pretty well
received upon yeah I should imagine it
is but this was more linked to the
Southland Hospital neither where they
basically could be a printout and say to
go home and go and if you haven't got
with JP support I should imagine a lot
of people go home and they couldn't
possibly do the exercises incorrectly
and do as much harm as good and I think
that was the area of concern so yes
execs if they're doing that but the
link-up was asked to investigate was
with actually with the hospital because
obviously most people what people go
through a hospital community can take it
away to exercise and health TD links
thank you
as independent it does still it
what
Figment what might be on sort of just
planets and say mention about all these
different
we've done to try and engage
using facilities
I just went to awesome is that fatigue
that IH we've being targeted or is this
generally covering for my degree was in
course inspector
since some are age-specific some that
this girl campaign is gender specific
and others
berries
it's time to solve it seemed like that
and we are we can try engage as many
people
yes but yet there are specific positions
as well
Thank You counsel Stanley
yes I'm pleased to hear that we've got
that whether it's evening we can come
back that's okay and we'll come out of
that humbug
in terms of weather fusion okay no that
would yes they do
there's a ratchet mechanism in the
contract if they don't I don't need to
take we've had to had to enforce that
ratchet mechanism but they do take notes
in terms of timing if it depends on the
time the weaver is appropriate to get
the individual piece of work done they
raise from the couple days to a week
month end piece of work but yet they do
they notice it's a strong piece of
something we can do don't joke no
contract
minutes
yes
we have
okay
there's am three items on that key to
document 3:18 the a one two seven air
quality project for some time but it's
coming up to her decision update I know
Martin Eric has met a couple of members
already that had concerns about thank
you for saying but if any member as an
issue which or would be happy to discuss
with you
then 1218 the advice services contract
for those unaware that's CIB and at the
moment is the CIB but it's come up for
tenure again and she said decision will
be made in December
and remember more information on that
these are all supply it or I can get
next meeting
all right and moving on the last one
thirteen nineteen the garden communities
prospectus
well if I read the subject matter to
endorse it during big to deliberately
feasibility work and evidence to support
spectrum and like you mean this would be
with a settlement
fishermen
for the chairman of the something to go
it's going to the executive obviously
it's a type date November day after the
next review committee
the monument was like management
seems like there might be more more to
this than meets the eye do we get any
more what I put them you probably get
Matthew Thomas to find a brief in know
you before we go before we go next week
no decision next week the decision be
made you know that pretty doesn't go to
you step back over the ingredient
breaking no wonder this week or early
next year
let's say you just make sure to say em
join join it's a city
[Music]
Jesus said Olivia I'm doing
okay we've had to change and social
being you risk male they can't reproduce
there's also the remembering of
tightening for changing countless
reception seals salt sort that one
yeah but our best on the next one yep
she said there will be the report
University Chancellor again no that's
what we can't hear anyway that's why
we're having a private uh besides
December there'll be the voice of the
councilman before the finally finish
[Music]
any news from mr. kotis we think he's
gonna turn up with no no he's obviously
but he's got a fish to fry we will have
to recall and by the end of this week
you will have the draft insertion for
the constitution doing